welcome along to this meeting of the
inago City council's Community
well-being committee um I don't have a
note of any
apologies but I'm guessing the mayor
will be back with us shortly I know that
he was on the phone just
before uh we have two items in uh
um in the public forum just as a brief
outline for the process this afternoon
we'll go through the community wellbeing
committee open Agenda then move into
public excluded at which point I'll
adjourn um people who are following us
on the live streams will then have a
moment to click over to the live stream
for the infrastructure Services
committee which we will go through that
and open meeting and then go into public
excluded and I'm not sure whether it's
infrastructure or it's probably easier
for us to finish with infrastructure and
then we'll come back with Community
well-being and committee at the end any
questions if not um then we'll get into
the first item uh in the public forum
and uh Rebecca amon's joining us on Zoom
to speak for Arts met heu welcome along
Rebecca thank you very much um sorry I
couldn't be there in person today but
I'm um actually away on holiday so um
yeah timing um but I thought it was a
good time to um connecting with the
council at a governance level about what
Arts Miku has been doing over the um
first part of this year actually um
we've been working a lot with various
staff um in the library hoko ipeg Civic
um kind of area and um yeah I thought it
would be a good time to sort of give you
a bit of a background of what we've been
up to um so for those of you who don't
know Arts Miku is Southlands region Arts
um body uh our role is to support the
Arts both across the sector so that's
all forms of the Arts not just Visual
Arts um as well as across the
region and for many years some of you
will have heard people talking about the
Arts needing to show some leadership um
so this year um largely as a result of
some funding that we've received from
the ministry for culture and Heritage we
have been able to step into that space
uh and we have a a regional Arts
strategy that was done in 2020 which
talks about the Arts needing to be
visible vibrant and valued and so that
is kind of our underlying motivation I
guess for the things that we um are
trying to
do so um in 2021 the ministry for
culture and Heritage got a bunch of
funding uh from the government to give
out to um Arts culture and AG
organizations across New Zealand in
order to support things in the sort of
postco um era and our funding
application to that was successful and
at this the week before Christmas it was
actually we found out that we were
successful in receiving
$448,000 um as part of that fund so the
project that we had put forward had a
few different uh tentacles because
because we feel like there's a lot of
work to to do in the art sector in
Southland um and so the first part of
that was around capability building for
the art sector and uh we had identified
a number of sort of reasons that that
was needed uh as well as a number of
actions that we could undertake in order
to support that so the main things that
we are doing for supporting the
capability building of the Arts um back
in June we ran an event called night of
the Arts which was an opportunity for
people from a variety of Arts um sectors
to participate in an event in the
CBD and uh despite the weather on the
30th of June uh that was a pretty
successful event and at the moment we
are running our second big event and I'm
not sure if you can see that on the
screen there but the Southland Arts
Trail so we actually ran the first one
of these last year uh and people uh
regions all around New Zealand have them
and Southland hasn't had one before uh
so it's an opportunity for artists to
open their Studios over a number of
weekends uh we are pulling it an Arts
trail with an S and the reason we have
done that is because we have included in
this brochure uh all of the Arts things
that we know about that are happening
between the 6th and the 23rd of October
and again this is an opportunity for the
art sector to Showcase itself to the
public um last year we had hoped to have
about 20 Studios open uh and we had 55 I
think all together um this year we've
done much the same thing um we've got
over 50 Studios open we have about 20
other events happening throughout that
time period that we promoting uh and
when you fold that out um there's a big
long list on the inside you can also
find it on our Facebook and website and
it was in last week's s Express as well
so those are two of the main things that
we're doing around capability building
but we are also developing a program
that will roll out in the new year and
we're test piloting sort of part of that
later this year uh we're calling it a
creative pathway so basically an
opportunity rather than just having lots
of one-off workshops um an opportunity
for people to kind of learn something
and then have some mentoring uh to sort
of keep on developing their skills so we
think that'll be pretty important um on
that sort of Journey for uh creatives as
well
we also have a community art space at
344 Street um and thanks to the council
it's a council owned um building that we
are Leasing and we are using that as
sort of a test place for people so uh we
haven't really had a community gallery
for a long time in inago and there's not
very many of them around the region
either uh and so this is a place for
people who are kind of new um to to run
events or exhibitions in a way where
they're supported um by other people and
those other people are our amazing staff
so as a result of the funding we have
finally been able to employ um we've uh
115 hours worth of people and I say it
in the hours because all together
there's four people but they're all
working part time sort of hours um and
so their job is to staff that Art Space
um help with promotion and that kind of
thing um of Arts activities and uh build
relationships with people in the Arts
Community across the region so that they
can develop their skills and have
somebody who that they can um help them
with different things so we've already
had some examples of that happened this
year um there was a lady who wanted some
help with a community project that she
wanted to do series of workshops uh she
had never applied for funding before and
so our team was able to work with her to
develop her project and then help her um
through the um funding application
process and which was
successful um the other part to all of
that that we are doing and it comes
through time and time again with all of
the uh sort of research we've done
around what the Arts Community needs and
that is more promotion and marketing and
publicity and all of that kind of stuff
so uh a few people who follow us on
Facebook um have almost complained that
now all they see on Facebook is arts
mahu and the stuff that we're doing
popping up um and the stuff that we're
helping promote as part of that so we're
promoting not just our own activities
but also the wider activities of the
Arts sector we also do a full page ad in
the Southland Express at the end of each
month which details all of the Arts
activities that are happening um in the
following month so uh and we're looking
at other ways we can continue to support
that uh the final thing that we have
done and we're just in the process of
finalizing it now is get a report done
we're calling it a baseline report so
basically um when we made the
application to the ministry for culture
and Heritage we um we had to describe
how what we would do would have a
long-term impact on the art sector in
Southland uh and one of the things that
we realized while we were putting that
together was we can't actually explain
what the long-term impact is if we don't
know where we've started so um this
report that's um that's just in the
final stages at the moment is what we're
calling a baseline report a snapshot of
what the art sector looks like now what
its challenges are and what its
aspirations are so that we can use it as
we go forward to measure the progress
against that that um that Arts Miku is
making but we also think that it will be
a valuable document for other funders um
and um other Arts organizations to use
um as they are developing projects in
things like that um going forward so
we're hoping to release that um maybe at
our AGM which will be at the end of
November um so yeah so I guess um that's
a bit of a summary of all of the things
that we're trying to do in a very short
amount of time the funding we received
has to be all used up by the end of June
2024 um so a time is of the essence and
we are trying to do as much as we can
and as quickly as we can um but we are
also at the same time trying to look to
see what we can do to secure future
funding in order to be able to carry on
what we're doing we think that um The
Gap that we are sort of filling now is a
gap that's been there for a really long
time and people have really wanted it to
be filled um and uh we need to now think
about how we can do that on an ongoing
basis um so yeah and I guess um the only
other thing would be to say that I'm
really interested to keep talking
talking with the council and I've
already mentioned that we've um we've
worked with the Civic Theater on the
Cabaret Festival um the library and
houia um both participated in the night
of the Arts and um heia is part of the
sapl Arts Trail um yeah so really Keen
to keep having conversations about how
we can keep working with the council and
supporting the council's goals um
especially around the things that you
have in your Arts culture and Heritage
strategy um one of the things that was
really important for us when we
developed our plan for this funding um
and and the funding proposal was to
ensure that the things we were aiming to
do aligned not only with the goals in
our Arts strategy but the other Arts
strategies around the region um so that
included the inago city council Arts
culture and Heritage strategy as well as
the community trusts um Arts culture and
Heritage Poe um as well as the work that
was being done through sort of going
right back to swords and that whole
thing around having a vibrant city um
vibrant cities need um a vibrant art
sector so yeah thanks Rebecca so just to
to recap then that uh MCH funding that
Arts metu has is really only for another
nine months have you any indication of
what happens beyond that uh so the
funding they got was um one off um
postco funding so at this stage that is
what the status quo is um creative New
Zealand who
is kind of an arm of um the ministry for
culture and Heritage is currently
revising um
their uh approach to funding
organizations and projects across the
country um so it's going to be really
interesting to see how that kind of um
evolves um they had some backlash with
how they delivered some funding earlier
this year and late last year which is
one of the reasons for that rethink from
them um so yeah so in that regard it's
all at a national level at least a bit
of a waiting game to see what will be
available and how it is going to be um
distributed do you know if there's any
vulnerability around um the outcome of
Elections this
weekend Oh I think there's always
vulnerability around elections um and uh
certainly uh I've just been at the
creative New Zealand conference in New
Plymouth a couple of weeks ago and
um regardless of who the government is
given um the more difficult Economic
Times that are
anticipated um there is certainly some
concern across the art sector that uh
that the art sector you know as always
will be the first one to suffer cuts um
even though the the things that the art
sector provides are so vital to
well-being of people and
communities thanks and congratulations
to artsu for the development of your
Arts Trail uh if there are people who
are going out to do the um voting on
actual election day this weekend they
could as they're leaving the house use
the brochure and navigate around and
visit some artists as well councilors uh
open for any
questions there are none Rebecca thank
you very much for zooming in during your
holiday and we'll let you resume your
leisure activities thank you very much
for having me thank
you uh Mr West we'll just get uh get you
to come up and take a seat Vic is
presenting on behalf of blind citizens
New Zealand and just a reminder
councilors that the matter that he's
raising will come up for discussion at
the infrastructure committee meeting
after
this welcome along Vic you're no
stranger to reporting to council um
we've had a chance to have a look at the
uh letter from from Carolyn so really
it's it's your time to provide us with
that
feedback yes um good afternoon um Mr
chairman and B counselors um I'm here
representing blind citizens in relation
to The jeel Pedestrian Crossing
signals um I'll have to add that while
the um one on the corner of St Andrew
Street um uh there is another one
actually was actually installed later
than that which is Gala Street West so
that that's included in the Dual pesan
Crossing signals now over the past U how
many months of just the The Crossing
signals themselves are very full of
static um the voice message is very hard
it's it's detectable but with the
traffic noise the voice message um if
you want the longer Crossing and push
the button in until a red light shows of
course that's no good to me but there is
a beep and I can't hear that and that's
really um not not particularly good for
totally blind people for us like that so
but um those are the three issues the
static um and the the voice message not
been very clear the um voice message
with the red light showing I believe
that's there but the the beep which
gives us the signal that you've got the
longer Crossing so those are the issues
that we want to sort out um and on one
of the on
the Queens Drive West there's no voice
message on that one and on the detected
on the other ones of the I say they're
full of static so we want to we want to
really have a clear message voice
message on
those um Mr chairman so I I and and I I
have raised the issue uh actually at the
last combined Disability Group meeting
and also send messages through from
request for service to have a look at
that so I don't know what why uh and I
had no information back today why it
needs to be like
that thanks F councilor pottinger thank
you uh thanks chair um it's Ian
pottinger here um on chair of
infrastructure committee which will be
looking at this my my first question and
and it's an important one
is the Dual Crossings have they been
working okay and have
degraded or have they always been hard
to get the
enunciation Clarity and the confirmation
tones well have they ever work good I
don't really know what at what point the
deterioration went you know maybe I went
up one day and I was kind of raise it
but I didn't but but they have worked
okay they have worked in the initial
stages oh yes they working for number
quite but I don't know what at what
point they started to
deteriorate I I just can't remember that
but I've raised it at least a couple of
year might even been a couple of years
ago at the same me infrastructure
meeting that that I didn't feel they
were working properly and I thought
perhaps they're waiting for a new part
or something like that or there might be
some problems with and Direction so I
never raised the matter again so and
then it wanted off and then one day I
went up and tried it and I thought this
is not good and I went to another one
and I said that's even just as bad and
and this this is um what I'm so I
thought well I need to get bring this
you know we um I I just feel that the
it's it's it's this is not good it's the
message the first message I remember cuz
we when we first opened it it was nice
and clear and I mean course course you
you remember have to contend with the
traffic sound at the back so um you know
that's that's important part of the
reason because um you know we we're
really big on um pedestrian safety on
those particularly on those wide
carriageways they're a bit of a
challenge you see so so what we've got
and this is good for our committee is we
we've got a priority service to get
these right we don't have to redesign
the wheel so that's what we can look at
and you mentioned another Crossing that
never had um the jewel Tes so we can
look at that as well no thank you for
that okay thank you Council has any
other
questions if not um thanks Vic we
appreciate you coming in we're sorry it
it got to this point um but we'll be
pretty Keen to to get it resolved thank
you thank you very
much
councilors I'll just pause for a moment
to wait for to to come
back can I yes request for service we
have a um certain procedure proes around
it this will come to my my committee so
you have to ask it yeah
y Jo yes um yes absolutely there is a
request for service system and if we
have a call about that that's we would
raise a request for service yes
thanks okay thank you councilors we'll
move on with the agenda and we have uh
the minutes of the creative communities
committee from uh December
which pretty sure I was there to be
fair um possibly not but I but you were
can you oh no I'm apology for that one
as
well don't think there's a c in that
case I'll move them Pro
former I'll second them on the same
basis thank you but that all in
favor against
carried uh creative communities uh
meeting from March
second I we s move I'll second that
any questions or
comments not I'll put that all in favor
I against carried and same committee
June 1 I'll move those ones I'll you
were an apology but you can I will
second
them put that all in favor I against
carried and our last one which was on
August 31st and it's worth noting that
at this point um our youth Council
delegate um Liam cder is now in the
chair's seat which is actually pretty
cool uh so I'm happy to Move It I happy
to see any
questions if not I'll put it that all in
favor against just a question about why
we got four in a
row good
question I had not realized I don't know
why that these had not been coming
regularly and um they are informative
only but um it's also not uncommon we're
getting a Year's worth in a
h um we'll see if we can make sure that
they're drip fed through more regularly
in the future the chair that is the
intention that they do come through um
regularly after the meetings uh this has
just been a catchup as we have
introduced this new system of the um
various subcommittees and um other uh
committees like the district licensing
committee actually reporting up and uh
the committee so it is a work in
progress that should have caught
everything up now thank you Mr chair to
uh Mr Morris for his elucidation on this
matter there's anointment for that we
have the community well-being committee
from September 12th move Barry seconded
Leslie any matters AR
Rising not to put that all in favor I
against carried speaking of the district
licensing
um that's the next one which I'm happy
to move second councilor kit any
questions put the motion all in favor I
against carried that brings us to uh the
Electoral legislation bill which
proposes the lowering of the voting age
for local elections and
polls uh
Michael car thank you Mr
chair so as you will all know uh the
Supreme Court uh in 2022 issued a
declaration saying that there was no
justifiable reason against the Bill of
Rights Act to keep the voting age at 18
which triggered a process through
Parliament uh this as the result of the
current government's thinking on this
knowing that it cannot make the change
to change it for the general
elections um because it requires a super
majority but can change it for local
government elections uh and that bill
was introduced pretty much on the second
to last sitting day of uh the current
term of
Parliament and it has invited uh
submissions to be made on uh this bill
which lowers the voting age to uh 16 for
all local elections with the exception
of uh licensing trust they made a policy
decision to keep a licensing trust
election at 18 years age because that is
the age you can buy uh
alcohol of course that creates um an
issue for us and a small number of other
councils because we also have a
licensing trust in our district it's not
an
insurmountable um issue just it's going
to be another iteration basically of a
voting paper for 16year olds within the
inago uh City boundary who are in the
licensing trust area um contacted our
provider for the elections and they
estimate that the increased cost to us
would be about
$44,000 um which in the context of the
election is relatively negligible uh but
is still in an increased cost that we
wouldn't have if this didn't change so
that is the basic synopsis of what is
happening the bill does makes a number
of changes to other um legislation but
they don't uh impact us they are things
like the mustard and mustard and lens
trust and things like that who have the
elections at the same time so the paper
is simply asking if the council wishes
to make a submission on this bill um and
if so whether it is for or against
um the lowering of the age uh and with
that I'm very happy to answer any
questions Council poer um this is purely
a question around the when you said
about the
50% majority required at local
government level now there's 67 councils
so is it the majority of the 67 who what
how does this swing of MPS and
Parliament of MPS and Parliament oh so
make the decision based on our feedback
even if there's 100% even if every
single Council said they don't agree
then the say yes say yes oh that's
democracy
working that's that's the theory and
that's the concept of parliamentary no
that's great yeah yeah what a great
country to live in but I I guess if that
was the case and let let's let's say
100% of councils did submit in
supporting the lowering of the voting
age in the government of the time decid
against it it kind of speaks volumes
about their willingness
to either way yeah both way yes yeah and
and we've had the same thing with you
know people have argued around um
written submissions uh in volume around
uh speed restrictions for example um
Council Arnold made that point we have
Alex Alex sorry um I just wanted to I
guess add and throw into the mix um some
context from future for local government
and the future for local government um
also had this as a priority as part of
the enhancing local democracy um in
order to increase access to
representation which part of it was the
V lowering the voting age for local
elections till 16 they had a um a Hy in
Wellington recently in which UH 60
councils were represented with over 120
people and the over 50% of the councils
were in favor or in favor with changes
of this so I think it's it's just worth
noting for context I suppose that there
is
a m
majority I don't know if you say that
but there's over 50% support just a
point of order there sorry for Alex is
when when you say the councils were in
majority it was their
representatives yes correct okay and I
clarified that at the start that 60 with
60 councils were there but the
representation poll of 120 people no no
no no but I'm saying the the people yeah
so it wasn't they didn't have a vote
like we're about to do some may have
well but but but yes you're right I'm
not saying they're all 100% in support
of correct I'm saying that there was a
poll of 60 councilors with 120
Representatives thank you M Clark so
that that just to clarify that because I
was actually there so that was a 120 was
a combination of Mayors Deputy Mayors
and chief
Executives um and certainly was split
down middle
um I guess my view on this is I think
it's a bit ironic that that central
government asks us for our view on going
to 16 year olds when they're not
prepared to attempt to go there
themselves now 75% might be a stretch
too far for Parliament but it may not be
but they're not even attempting to put
it up at this stage um and I think the
consequences of being in favor of young
people voting at 16 regards to the
argument the way is that we know by
history that older people tend to vote
in local government and younger ones
don't and that's not because they're not
given the options because the 18 to 25
year olds or whatever it is do have the
option but tend not to vote and what
will I think what we'll end up is we'll
end up with a situation we will have
even a lower percentage of participation
because if we add a whole lot of young
people in and they don't vote because
they don't care less they don't have an
interest in local body
um then instead of us having 55% we'll
end up with 45% or whatever um so my
personal view is we should just take the
neutral stand until we see where the
land lies with the central government if
they're prepared to have a go then we
should have a go too Beasley thank you
Mr chair um first of all I want to say
that the Supreme Court making a
declaration of
inconsistency is a very major thing for
our Supreme Court to do the Declaration
of inconsistency against their Bill of
Rights Act happens on very rare
occasions it has happened on a few
occasions but very rarely I think we
have to take that seriously um I would
like to see
us put in a submission on this I
personally think that it should happen
there is a justifiable reason why you
would not lower the age for licensing
trusts and that is that term is very
very important in the Bill of Rights act
because justifiable reason is the reason
that you don't have an inconsistency um
and it's obviously to do with the the
legal age for
alcohol I all but the other reason I
would like to see us put in a submission
is that it gives us the P perfect
opportunity in a submission to again
point out what is actually local
government New Zealand policy as well
that there should be Civics education in
schools as part of any lowering of the
voting age in New Zealand and here is an
opportunity for us to State it again why
do we not have a Civics program in our
schools because that would answer many
of the issues people bring up about
whether our young people are point where
we would get a low turnout Etc Civics
education is known by International
research to make a difference and we
know also from International research
that the earlier you start your voting
the more likely you are to be a
continual voter from that point on so I
would like to see us make a submission I
would like to see us make a submission
in favor but I would also like to see us
in our submission include the Civics
education thank you
Tom to some extent Leslie has already
said what I was going to say um the uh
voting age
uh was lowed in Scotland actually 16 in
2015 in fact it was lowed a year earlier
than that for the referendum
Independence referendum and then was led
for elections in in h 2016
2015 but um the teaching of civics in
school had started in
2006 so they had nearly a 10 years um of
preparation
for that and I I think I'm agreen liely
that um you know I think if we are
putting in a submission I think that's
an important point to make I I don't
personally favor lowering the voting age
now but I I would do if we had you know
a few years ago and casting forward a
few years in the future if we had um if
we taught Civics in school and and by
the way you know the world never came to
an end when the Lord V age to 16 in
Scotland but not aot of people voted but
um people voted pretty responsibly but
again the 10 years of civics training
the
schools thank you Ria then Evelyn just
thank you Mr chair just very quickly I'm
supporting what the mayor and lizy both
said I do think that um I support a
neutral submission going forward given
the indicators are that the potential
next government um does not support this
but I do support us pulling through a
neutral submission to to tease that
really
um what can happen after these
elections Mr chair um so I support what
council soia has said um for the reasons
what she stated and noting that that Tom
has Pro uh councelor Campbell has
provided a concrete example of the
benefits of civics education and and
seeding the ground beforehand I think
the prospect of us making this decision
and expecting um a big turnout two years
later when we haven't done this when we
as a society have not done this work to
to prepare our 16 year olds for the
responsibility that they're being
offered is probably um fairly futile um
so whilst
I and mindful that in the past this
table has said no to s belowing the age
to 16 because we actually talked about
it um relatively
recently I do think it's an aspiration
that we should support along with the
Civics education and also recognizing
that here and in a number of other
places the the education has got to
include the why you can't vote for
alcohol related issues at the age of 18
just as you wouldn't be able to um vote
if it was a smoking related issue if you
were under the age of 18 one assumes um
so a referenda about
smoking um should the should we young
people be offered the opportunity if
they're not legally allowed to smoke
they won't I imagine be allowed to vote
on that basis either I think as a
council we should be looking forward and
we should be
saying that
a well educated Society will make better
decisions on Civic matters including
local body governance if they know what
it is they're voting for or against so I
thank you for the opportunity to support
Council saa's
suggestion one point of clarification Mr
Morris thank you um just thought it' be
helpful to point out the bill isn't
proposing that the age be lowered until
the 2028 elections oh my go that
wouldn't be the 2025 it's the next next
ones Alex and then Council P um thank
you um I agree with leslee I think that
we definitely should put in a submission
but I personally probably not quite
surprisingly don't think that we should
be particularly neutral about it I think
um the mayor is quite right in saying
that obviously the statistics don't lie
when it shows that the um 18 to 24 year
old demographic doesn't turn out to vote
but but that's because they've been
living in a system that hasn't respected
their beliefs for the entire time that
they've been paying into it they leave
you know like they get their part-time
job they go and pay tax the same way
that anybody else does they you know
purchase Goods they pay GST they've been
you know like they have the same
parameters that we have as adults
arguably with you know some constraints
like alcohol for want of a b or not want
but we haven't listened to them since
the but and but we will take their money
and I really am thankful that um the
deputy M brought up the fact of Scotland
um Ving v um turnout because they the
long-term study now that actually shows
that when you get voters um that that
electoral data that for Scotland shows
that turnout is low when voters are in
their early years of adulthood and then
it increases from from mid to late 20s
and the 16 to 177 year old when they're
enfranchised they then continue um to
vote in greater numbers in the 18 to 24
year old bracket so it's exponential
it's a lag measure if you start it now
and you give them the opportunity Civics
education and you get them enfranchised
in the and and voting it will increase
exponentially it's not something that
we're just going to you know like turn
the switch on and overnight all of a
sudden all the 16 and 17 year olds going
to start voting but they will once they
do at 16 and 17 continue and start to
grow as they age and I think that is the
benefit you know and when the May says
oh they don't turn out and vote we don't
even give them the opportunity to you
know like or the opportunity to get
entrenched in Civics and entrenched in
the system so I yeah I'm personally of
the belief that we should actually not
be taking quite such a neutral
position thank you councelor Pinger yes
I agree we shouldn't be taking such a
neutral position um we actually I think
we need to be consistent this country
needs to be consistent we can't look at
changing of the voting age and isolation
without looking for example at our
justice court system which makes it
quite clear that 16 and 17y old
offenders are actually given more
allowances and leniencies
because of their lesser decision making
capabilities and the emphasis is more
focused on Rehabilitation than
punishment now this comes they they've
done this from medical science which
proves the prefrontal prefrontal cortex
which governs your decision making
processes it's not developed at this age
so on one hand we can we can say yes 16
and 17 year olds oh you did that wrong
but you your brain wasn't developed so
we're going to give you allowances and
then on the other hand we're going to
say hey you can go and vote for any
candidate you want to um which is a a
major decision so sorry there's a ma
there's a great
inconsistency if the voting age is
changed so I do agree we need to put
forward a submission and I would
argue that the age should not be dropped
because of those very
reasons thank you councilor Stewart yep
ringy you just about hit it right on the
nail uh I'll be voting against it for
one because they a I don't think the
their brain brain is developed enough to
make big decisions like this so that's
what that's where where all be with
Council Arnold then councilor broad um
yeah I'll be voting against it as well I
just think at the age of 16 I think let
young people go out and enjoy themselves
they can worry about elect the electoral
system as they as they as they get a
little bit older if anything i' I'd
rather prefer the age went up not
down there we go thank you I do note
that many 18y olds go out and enjoy
themselves as well Council
abroad um I'm for a submission um to low
and I was actually a hard no until the
by elction uh and our young people on a
youth specific uh meeting turned out um
in huge numbers and I think articulate
articulated
themselves um best in any of the
meetings and ask some powerful important
questions uh that that that swayed me
based on also some research I've done
again to Leslie's point the Bill of
Rights is relatively clear around this
um I agree with Tom around the the union
of of civics education underlying this
and underpinning this um whether it's an
on ramp 2
2028 um it also another countries has
been used as a trigger to start teaching
Civics in schools which is really
important um
yeah and in some cases has improved
voter turnout as well so take time to
point to what done in Scotland as well
thank you anyone who hasn't spoken AP
from me who wants to have a
say I'll give you another bite of it
thank you because I'm not the first to
have a second bite of it um look um I'm
only neutral because I want the
government to take a steer on us they
they're taking the path of least
resistance by local body to agree to it
it's a little bit like amalgamation we
were hopeful that we'd get some steering
that we didn't really get a steer on it
and know and nothing will be en enacted
within that report on amalgamation
because the big is the question that if
we amalgamate down to 25 councils then
why do you need 60 um electoral um seats
for central government and this is no
different an issue um I'd be in favor of
of looking to review if several things
would have happen one that central
government was prepared to put a voice
up and say we hear what the Supreme
Court says about the Bill of Rights so
we're going to ask for some legislation
that brings both national elections and
local body elections to alignment and
allows it to be dropped to thir to 16
because it it big is the challenge that
if if they can vote in a a local body
election at 16 why can't they vote in a
national election at
16 why is there a difference um
and they could also remove the 75%
provision as well if they wanted to but
they elect not to um and so um so
government's got the central role and
all of that's not us and the second
thing I guess is that I think everybody
around the table has reflected that we
need some education in schools secondary
schools around this issue and again
that's a Ministry of Education something
that we have no say over but it's a
government function again that needs to
be implemented you wouldn't allow
somebody to change the rules on driving
a car and just say ah you can drive a
car at 4 in tomorrow you'd actually want
to school them up and we've got a window
of opportunity here as we lead into the
2028 elections which as you say is two
elections away to allow the the ministry
on behalf of the government to do some
education so people are a bit more
skilled on what they might want to
participate in so um hence my neutral
thing but um if I'm forced to vote I'll
vote
against thank you uh and bearing in mind
that the first time the mayor spoke was
representing what had happened in that
meeting so I'm just conscious of making
sure that everybody has one chip at it
before I go through it recommendation by
recommendation anyone else who hasn't
spoken yet that hasn't already spoken
yet that wants
to no in that case I'll finish off um
could I I do have why why would it be an
exception counselor correct because I'd
like to speak as well and that's and
that's the can that opens you allowed
the mayor to speak twice the first time
I allowed the mayor to speak he was
talking about how the meeting that
Council of
crack two guys as well and I just wanted
to clarify that a super majority cannot
be cont
okay so right ringy that was all I
wanted to say I let speak quickly mine
was a clarification
only no it's not a clarification it was
just purely to be you got you got to be
18 to on a house you got to be 18 to go
to the Army you got to be 18 to get
married um and no you don't yeah you do
need a court a family court judge to you
don't need to be 18 and then once you
get married as a 16y old have full
rights of an 18y old but um okay you can
take in the house ownership that's
against the Bill of Rights isn't it
can't own a house why AR they changing
that not helping to advance things a
whole lot okay um um initially
uh I I don't see what what it was that
was so scary about giving 16 year olds
to vote in in in local government
elections because in some cases well
first of all there's that whole lack of
Engagement from the general population
and maybe there was a chance to increase
that by giving uh younger people that
opportunity but I think to say that a
young person wouldn't think as much
about how they cast their vote as an
adult as
fraught um because if the commentary I
see on social media is anything to go by
there's a whole lot of adults that don't
do a lot of thinking either um doesn't
mean you make it worse I'm just saying
that the it's the same I think Tom's
point about the Scottish example and
it's very different to the three Waters
example which we're not so thrilled
about um is a really good one and if
young people get that opportunity giving
them the opportunity to understand what
cives first I think sets a a really
sound platform and and that's the sort
of thing that we could encourage I think
potentially with a
neutral um submission if if that's where
we wanted to go
um so first of all we the first
recommendation is that we receive the
report so I'll move that seconded
councilor SOA put that all in favor I
against carried now it's whether we want
to uh do or do not want to make make a
submission I'll move that we do make a
submission second
okay so uh moving that we do make a
submission those in favor raise your
hands
please
Carri um now we would need to confirm
the submission is four against or
neutral so indicatively
four two three four
against neutral can we vote twice
because neutal yeah yeah through through
you CH my my view is that the something
which I think is common to almost
everybody in this room whether they're
for or against is the critical nature of
the Civics training in schools before
such a change can be made so so we could
make a neutral submission which stressed
that point and said that you know over
you about for or against really depends
on whether the point of order sorry we
are voting on the recommendations
actually I hadn't asked people to vote I
was asking them to
indicate so the your point of order is
is turned down um what I don't have is a
motion and Tom move the motion that we
present a neutral submission I'll second
that okay those in favor raise your
hand yeah just a point of order I'm not
sure how you you go to a select
committee if that's where it's going to
be and make a submission that's
neutral just don't go because that's
going to be the
next time we make recommendations that
don't need to be in particular for I
mean you know my position on it but if
if I was to I note the comment but I
haven't actually finished taking the
vote sorry so those who supported the
neutral no um your hands all went down
before we'd finished voting R so if you
support it hand up for the neutral
submission one two three four five
Carrie Mr chair I believe that what is
missing from this is the staff
recommendation um about the um speaking
to the Civics thing well that's what I
picked up that they what they were
drawing to our attention was
that and the contradiction for us of or
the complication for us of the licensing
trust situation so I think that whilst
we can be saying that we're neutral
we're indicating to um government the
complications that arise with
legislation like this for discreet
councils that have a
different set of so where I was Hing to
sorry was that there is an opportunity
for us to uh introduce another
recommendation Council or the committee
has said that it's neutral that can also
recommend that the submission contain
the recommendation that one Civics is
introduced to schools first if there is
to be any consideration of lowering the
age and potentially too that um as as
mayor Clark said uh that the issues
around the Bill of Rights are reexamined
there's a form of um Equity between
voting for local government and central
government so if
sorry I'll move there I think we also
need to move that the submission
includes some reference to the licensing
trust issue yes agree thank you sorry
chair are we going to see that in
writing it's going to be pop up here you
just wear a red shirt with a white cross
and that's neutral or a Target yeah
yeah just give us a
moment there is another
issue in that's in around the the timing
of when the submission go but we'll deal
with that
next one
read that will be something of a moot
point here if if the legislation if the
bill is actually
removed possibly but in the moment it's
it's there and we we deal with it well
it's technically not the because
government government has Ren Parliament
has Ren so every every bill before
select at the moment has the potential
for it no longer
to excuse me chair just while you're
doing that can we just have a just a an
update on that vote again just for my
own uh you know how many for and how
many against and the ability to well
when we last the vote which was for a
neutral submission there was a majority
of hands yeah no sorry what was the
number sorry I didn't take account I saw
a majority of hands okay so you're
greater than seven yes right anyone
disagree with that no no no no I just
didn't see the seven hands sorry through
you chair um if you put a a clause in
there like number four that you're
including there now you're basically
sort of saying that if if you do these
things then we might be happy for it the
age voting to be lowered yeah whereas
the indication to me before was that
most people here were against lowering
it to 16 so I don't know that we should
be making any recommendation to suggest
that if they do these things we'll
change their mind because I won't change
my mind that's not saying that at all
that's what it's suggesting think no
that's how you're reading it I I think
the motion talks about the shortcomings
in the situation as it is currently
yes Trish yes that's what I was Voting
against I was Voting against as it was
I'm much happier to vote as number four
that's saying this is what we need and
if the information is then I'll vote
positively I
will yeah but I think you have to sort
of take take a numbers vote again then
because I'm actually changing age to 16
full
stop we already had a majority but we
had a majority for
that majority for Mak a neutral
submission neutral means was a
submission means when you said or
against lowering the age most against
thank you I have the chair good yeah the
majority vote was for making a neutral
submission that was the last vote that
we took the last vote
Yes so the motion that was sorry who the
recommendation
Trish Les M Clark yeah look I think
we've dug ourselves into a bit of rabbit
hole here um so we we'll need to
backrack otherwise we're going to be in
a real rabbit hole if we don't
if I go forward and do a submission um
wherever I need to go to be at the
select committee I should be in a
position to say look here's where it
landed with um um with our counsil we
had let's say for I'm sake five in favor
and seven or eight were not in favor but
of the eight that weren't in favor we
would probably have a majority in favor
of lying the voting age if there was
some work done in the next 5 years at
schools to prepare these 16 to 18 year
olds now if that's the case I should be
able to say that at the moment I'm not
sure I have because most of the people
that uh voted for the neutral I don't
know how many are neutral and how many
are
actually ding that's I'm not going to
grieve to 16y Old regardless of what
happens at school can see so I think
that's partially because people have
changed their minds as we've gone
through I think what it's what this
recommendation is calling for is uh
including in the submission where some
of the shortcomings lie and that we
remain neutral at the moment but these
are issues that need to be addressed
before people could make it considered
Choice mindful that 2028 is a long way
away we could come back and say to them
6 months from now to the new government
whoever that is uh we hear what you're
saying you're not going down the track
yourself or alter alternatively you are
prepared to do some works for the
Ministry of Education we'll give you
another indication from Council where we
stand on that issue it it could be that
a new select committee changes the the
playing field yep we don't know but this
is the one that we're we're dealing with
currently which has its own
shortcomings because I think the I think
the neutral vote was a combination of
those who are neutral and those that
were opposed and if we split that out
then we're going to be in an even worse
rabbit hle and I but I I think some of
the people are in the neutral vote also
supported the lowering of the age
because see it wasn't going to go that
way correct so
okay um all you can do is point out
where we sat at in the submission it
doesn't have to be voluminous but oh try
out here again you can see the
recommendation mve Trish and Leslie all
those in
favor against
I Barry Peter ring record alen thank you
you want your votes recorded
absolutely right now we need um do you
want to explain the timing issue for me
please Michael yes thank you Mr chair so
the submissions are due uh in by the
20th of October which is a relatively
short uh cycle um so there is two ways
that can we can achieve uh this the
submission can be delegated and have its
approval delegated to the mayor and
a number of counselors one other
counselor for example or um working with
the mayor there would need to be an
extraordinary council meeting next uh
Tuesday after the after or before the
finance and projects committee to
approve
the um submission once drafted so they
couldn't be lodged in time so either
option works it's just the 20th of
October is before the last before the
next council meeting CL just for
clarification who are we doing the
submission
to so it is going to the uh jce select
committee select committee yes so we'll
have a choice of either just doing a
submission or alternativ doing a
physical submission as well we got the
two options yes so we'll need to decide
on that because this will still have to
go to council at the end of the day for
Council yes so um thank you Mr Mayor the
intention was if it is delegated to
yourself and another counselor to
approve that it would be taken to full
Council um at the 31st of October for
council's information uh but the safest
option of course is to organize an
extraordinary council meeting uh through
your office and I think that might be
the best option yeah yeah yeah is it
possible to doesn't have to be a huge
submission but bearing in mind that it's
probably got to be ready by Thursday the
submission can be drafted I can um work
with that and have a draft through to
the mayor to review um tomorrow
afternoon not it be helpful to know
whether we want to just do a written
submission or whether we want somebody
to physically front up at the select
committee which would beon so would it
be an appropriate time to make that
decision M CL when we when we've had a
chance to see the paper if we can call
an extraordinary council meeting uh
before or after financing projects to to
knut that out y
okay um we don't have an indication yet
though when it will set because it will
take the incoming government whoever
they are some time to the set select
committees so is that a decision we have
the process is open now no about the
physical submission as opposed to the
written y yes I'd ask you when you make
your
submission whether you wish to present
in person or not okay so the
extraordinary meeting next week is the
best way of dealing with that no that's
fine thank you I just need so case we do
not need we don't need number five five
okay
thank you for your tolerance and your
contribution through that and we will
have a chance before next Tuesday to see
what the submission looks like and
decide whether or not we're there in
person or just making it as a written
submission so Che we haven't voted on
five yet have we just about two and so
just before oh sorry no five was the
comment that I just made we don't need
to correct y just go full Council yep y
okay uh does that will bring that in
thank you thank you sorry Mr chair is
live streaming down uh so the live
stream video is down at the moment uh
there is it's linked somehow weirdly in
the audio Zoom but the audio is still
working so um we will get through this
part and then it should res Set uh with
your committee
starting it's all right
okay draws breath that brings us to the
activities report um and just
since the um customer interactions and
the uh customer services is in there can
I extend my thanks to the staff who
worked um above and beyond during the
recent uh heavy rains and and weather
events uh Fielding a large number of
calls from people to make sure that they
were provided with the information that
they needed and that we were able to
respond to their questions and concerns
thank you very much for
that any questions on any of the items
in the activities report counselors
I had question sorry who was that then
Lesley and then Grant sure I'm right
it's page 54 it's to do with parking can
you just pull that mic in please pardon
sorry it's to do with
parking um I find it P page
54 60 to 90
um 56
here yes seems an awful lot so again and
this was come up at the last two
meetings um bearing in mind that we're
reporting against a previous year when
es street was closed oh right okay thank
you uh Lesley thanks Mr chair it's not a
question it's just a comment the Q
kindergarten memor of of understanding
um I just wanted to say congratulations
to our staff for for for putting that
together for The Penton Street
playground it's almost an nirro schools
um project and it's just really pleasing
to see it there and I look forward to
the being some more such memorandums of
understanding as
appropriate just before coming to you
grant welcome back to those who have
persisted through the audio only part of
the live stream Grant yeah thanks chair
um couple of questions just with your
comment about the um recent weather
event do we do a review of that in terms
of what customers required through that
period to sort of reflect you know the
next time we see a weather event coming
what we need to be ready for is there
any sort of postevent review done of you
know customers likes of I know I've had
a bit of feedback about um you know
significant amount of leaves around
drains because there was strong winds
before the rain came and it led to
probably more flooding than people
thought should happen as an example now
I'm not saying that is why it happen
but Jo
y from a customer service perspective of
course those things are quite hard to
plan for um we were able to bring more
people onto the phones and still manage
to answer like 90% of the course within
2 minutes and the crew stay till 7:00 um
from the infrastructure perspective I'll
hand across to Aon thank you I guess my
question is is there's some coverage of
this item in the activities report in
infrastructure committee are you happy
to hold into the discussion in in that
committee for that item yeah okay and
then second one is related to page four
of 9 of the report um just in terms of
the media numbers there
um is is that are we communicating
effectively with their
um how do I quantify that question yeah
that's right
um you know because I'm getting feedback
that there's certain parts around the
museum for example of our community that
just are very know very little about it
and that concerns me and you know I I
wonder you know how effective our
communication strategy is to reach
people with the information that we need
or want to be able to reach them with so
what's actual just before I cross to
Lisa for a response on that I guess it's
it's not like and you and I know that
the information's been going going out
there and and we're putting it out but
sometimes it really is a case if you can
lead a horse to water um and and how
people are receiving information now and
and where they get it from has has
shifted hugely
Lisa uh thank you chair um I agree with
you your comments um but to that I will
add that
for the museum and for everything that
we do we very much take a multi-channel
approach to get across as many different
channels as we have access to of course
we're always going to have the challenge
of reaching everyone across the
community um I think that's a challenge
that everyone shares um and you know
we'll continue doing what we can to
understand new channels utilize all of
those that we have to reach all of the
different
audiences um this report while it
reports on the
media I think it's really difficult for
us to display in this report all of the
different ways that we do communicate
because there are only certain things
that we have numbers for and so this is
really just a snapshot of
that okay secondary so suppose my
question is then how are we engaging
those um people in the community that
need to be connected to what we
do or the
museum I'm not sure there's a Magic
Bullet for that because if people don't
want to engage not we can't just sit
here and say well we've tried our best
and people aren't engaging you know if
you if you to run a business like that
you know open the doors and oh no
customers come along oh well it's not a
fault we've tried I mean you wouldn't be
very successful so you know you've got
to actually be very clear on what your
communication strategy is and who you're
trying to reach so if we were only
taking a single stream approach I would
agree for example during the pandemic
lockdowns businesses weren't able to
trade as they usually could and many
didn't have the capacity to be able to
trade online and yet Solutions were
produced for them very quickly but it
was a case of finding how you needed to
Pivot and it's the same in in
Communications um there's just some
stuff that
people you you'd almost need to put up
full frontal nerdity in some to to get
some attraction try something
Sensational in order to attract
someone's attention that's just a
metaphor don't suggesting that's not
what I'm suggesting I'm not suggesting
as Project Lead Grant although if you
wanted the
traction um Lisa did you have a response
to Grant's point just regarding the
museum uh there is a Communications
strategy for that gr which is currently
being refreshed and I believe we have a
meeting about thator tomorrow so I'm
happy to run you through the finer
details May Clark yep just wanted to add
to what uh Grant was saying I don't
think we have a wide enough spread so
I'll say what I need to say on that
because it it won't sit well with some
people um there is a reluctance by this
Council to use whats on numbers because
of some traditional baggage with them I
guess but they have a $50,000 strike
rate 50,000 client base it regly Taps
into them so as you say gr they're
people that will not necessarily come to
a city council website unless they're
looking for other stuff that's related
the city council they don't see us as a
primary need and the other area is the
area of the Express magazine it goes out
weekly another source that if we're not
using we should be using because that
goes to really box in the city and it's
free so we do do need to put aside some
of our resistance to using other
mechanisms I think and and get the
messages out there like I don't I don't
personally like Facebook I don't go on
to Facebook so if you want to reach me
you've got to find another mechanism so
we've all got different ways of
communicating we should be using every
single one of
them
so um Mr chair on the basis
of the comments I
think we all have people in our Lives
who need to be encouraged to um seek
information for
themselves um personally I as much as I
can um share the city's many
different um Communications on Facebook
that's something that I can do as well
as my personal interactions with people
I just don't think
that our communication staff or we as a
council are responsible for the people
who um want everything to come to them
directly personally because it's not
within our ability to to
do I think Council uses media quite well
um some people in media might say we
could do better that's okay I'm open to
that but I just think that listening to
the you know we all have people that
complain we all have people who
comment mine would be a mixed bag and I
guess most of ours would be as well and
some people say oh I wouldn't have known
if you hadn't shared I miss out on
things also not just from Council but
from other organizations it's my
responsibility um how much more do we
need to say to people about what is
going on with the museum CU I think I
worry that we're in danger of
overloading people actually I feel I
feel quite differently so I I guess it
depends on where you're sitting and how
people engage how much they pick up and
how much can our coms team or or we as a
council do about it don't know the
answer it is Frau and bearing in mind
I've spent 90% of my life working in the
media starting in and print and both
dailies and and free communities
um uh radio news television and now
Community radio and in the communication
sector the only way in the modern
context is a multi-platform approach and
trying to get a message out there but
that the downside of that is that each
one of those um forms of media uh you
can put out a press release there's no
guarantee that they're going to um go
with it the only way you can guarantee
it is to buy advertising space and and
that's what the all after because they
are in the business of of making money
and as a business it becomes
increasingly difficult to get your
message out there because it costs so
much more um but I guess if we weren't
trying and and looking at new things if
I look at how we've changed how we
engage just in recent years as opposed
to previously um you know some of the
the quirky videos that councilors have
been involved in putting together in an
effort to just try and get people's
attention to an issue to start the
conversation um or or arouse their
curiosity um that's the best that we can
do the one thing that we know with the
museum is that the people just want it
they want it badly they want it there
they want us to have it there
yesterday
um anecdotally the feedback that we've
had on the um option that's been put in
front of them has been really positive I
think people are excited about
uh the design I think some people are
probably less excited about chasing
their small people up and down the
exterior of the building but the
exercise might do them good um but it's
it's it's good to raise and good that we
we keep having the conversation and
looking to make sure that we get things
out there and you really don't have to
appear in a towel I'm
planning any other um items through the
activities report that anybody rear yes
please I'm just looking at um Bo page 57
at the um building and planning areas
and I noted that we have a um 11%
downturn of um co- compliance
certificates issued within 20 working
days and I wondered what were those
factors Jonathan so through you chair
I've reviewed each of those instances
personally um there are some
complications with our process it's
quite manual and it requires us to stop
and start clocks a number of times if we
miss one point it can have a backflow
effect so it's something we're
monitoring closely I'm confident
there'll be an improvement in the next
month great thank you thank you Peter
yeah thanking just about
the the events at rugby park mainly
rugby on those five NPC days there was a
lot of hold up at the uh The Operators
at the terminal selling the was they
report back on an instant report log
book CU it was very slow some people
were queued up 20 minutes after the
start of the game not that they were
late there it was just very very very
slow at assuring tickets were they
buying tickets or being buying tickets
for the tourist a lot of them were
yelling out say just take my money I
just want to go onto the terus it's a
great answer great example of why people
should buy their tickets before they go
not a walk up Sten if if you're wanting
a ticket in the stand you choose your
ticket but a walk up crowd families
wanted to
go won't make up their mind until the
day because of the
weather so uh very very slow indeed
quick question is it possible for people
to buy those tickets
online Joe yes yep on their phone as
they walk up and all they would need to
do is scan in them for those that are
able to to do
that uh it's not the first time cuz it's
gone on for a couple of years since and
I stood in one of those cues till way
through the first half of a game because
I didn't go and buy tickets beforehand
was the last time I made that mistake
last season it wasn't the it wasn't the
last season that I had that issue but
I've never gone along without buying a
ticket beforehand since okay I passed
along you can also buy them at the Civic
or here you know prior to the game as
well yeah for those who aren't online
corre y thank you thanks for raising the
point Peter anything else through the
activities report
Tom something which isn't in the
activities report but I've got no doubt
some as we've been hearing it about is
the question of parking infringements
and the extent to which people feel that
that has been
um H fairly heavily
pleased um and I just wonder whether
there's nothing in the activities report
but I think it does Fallen you know
there is because it was raised before
well where is it uh at the front
activities
report well as part so the number of
infringements has gone up
yes and generally people don't thank you
for it sorry what I was getting at was
you know that is I apologize what we
what we don't see in that report is um
how many have been challenged you know
maybe how many are in the system as a as
a a challenge to the infringement
notice I don't know that we've ever had
the challenges um reported on for
example I challenge no I'm not saying it
it it has been in the past what I'm
saying is that we are you know I I don't
maybe nobody else is but I'm certainly
hearing um you know people come to me
and complain about that it would just be
it would be useful to see how many
infringement notices have been
challenged it's yeah I guess it's going
to be really awkward to try and quantify
because me I got a parking infringement
and challenged it because I had paid but
I had entered the wrong one transposer
one number um and was able to prove that
I had paid it but and that was fine but
there will be people who feel like they
I was only parked on that um disability
park for a
minute less tolerance of that may Clark
you probably take a lot of calls about
this just as a bit of a point of order
on this I've got a late item to raise in
public excluded about this matter and I
don't think it's appropriate that we we
in an open environment start discussing
um parking complaints cuz that's not
just about tickets it's about how we
apply the the process as well okay well
Council would need to agree to take oh
committee would need to agree to take
that as a late item but Johnson sorry
did
you so through you chair um I think it's
fair to say this is the most proactive
um we've been able to be um within a
parking space we are aware um when we
have had feedback and we're taking that
on board and we are taking steps to
engage with the community regarding
their expect of parking infringements
and how they they're dealt
with
okay P
sorry just
different could you pull a microphone
around thank
you oh sorry um so literally M I just
want to say great to see that building
consense being issued within 20 days
fantastic work guys but my one's really
around dangerous buildings so buildings
that are in poor state that are
causing um dangerous situations how are
they monitored only because I know a
couple in Bluff that have been reports
through to the council but never seen
anything in any of the
reports so again through you chair we we
have a building compliance team who are
a separate arm to the building
consenting team they monitor the
situation um again with dangerous
buildings the process can be somewhat
protracted we have to give the owner
every opportunity to address the issue
uh that can sometimes take time um
certainly I am aware of um number of
buildings um not just in Bluff but in
the city also we are um taking steps
proactively as to reporting on them um
there is a potential for us to provide
details around dangerous building
notices issued and we would probably
need to consider privacy issues as
well yeah I'm I'm just sort of
highlighting one that where we've had
multiple pieces of block flying off a
building I mean just fortunate there nor
was that actually in the car park well
no vehicles been sort of damaged today
but it they do become um a
hazard yes and should that be the case
we do um we a lot of the time we rely on
people to proactively contact us and let
us know that that is
happening thank you I'll come back to
your point in a moment mby is there
anything else from the activities
report somebody like to move that it's
um
received and Barry put that all in favor
against carried so mayor Clark what was
the item you wanted wanted to introduce
as a late item for PX and what's the
reason for being in PX um so the issue
is around some public concerns that have
been raised around our parking
enforcement team and the reason for it
to be in public exclud is because it has
some implications for
staff so what
section uh Michael moris we'll give you
that it will be um section
72 and then the subsection after that
which can't quite remember I think it
might be a which is personal privacy of
um natural
persons thank you so you're moving that
as
a second seconded by Council
put that all in
favor against carried which brings us to
going to public excluded to discuss that
issue along with the minutes um public
excluded minutes of creative communities
December 8 March 3 June 1 and August
31st and the public excluded session of
the last Community well-being committee
and for each those it's under Section
721 uh to enable local authori ities
holding the information sorry I is it 72
I so it is use the progressives and um
the grounds is under Section
481 a
correct uh for each of of those um
and we don't need because they're
minutes we don't need to identify a
release date correct right taking those
collectively I'll move seconded Evelyn
put that all in favor I against carried
we now uh adjourn and